passenger cars account for a fifth of
europe's co2 emissions cutting emissions
of new cars by 2020 was given the green
light at the plenary plans include
encouraging manufacturers to use
lightweight materials for new models but
one of the big incentives to reduce the
carbon footprint are super credits for
manufacturers to produce eco-friendly
cars that emit 50 grams per kilometer or
below
the super credits
garba and the industry from eben
less than one percent the proceeds of
crime some 2.1 trillion dollars are ever
seized by authorities time for
europe-wide approach
new rules will allow national
governments to better trace and track
where money is being laundered across
the eu also on the cards are rules which
will allow for the confiscation of
assets transferred to third parties but
without criminal conviction crime
is very much focused on money on wealth
on assets
an awful lot of criminals of course
cannot conduct other criminal activities
without money
the issue of course is that we need to
take action internationally to try and
make sure
uh that we can confiscate the assets
that have been put together accumulated
by criminal activity
new rules are on the way to better
protect the rights of migrants to study
train research and work in europe two
directives are being merged so that
rules across member states are better
harmonized the hope is to make europe
more attracted to highly skilled third
country nationals so that their talent
can then be fostered to make europe more
competitive we have in europe
free mobility for for people to travel i
have spoken to so many research students
and they told me that they need to go
fingerprint their their thumbs and their
fingers once a year with the with the
migration authorities does that make
sense